you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
the met office issues its first ever
extreme heat warning
as parts of the uk bake in record
temperatures
as european leaders say more action is
needed to tackle global warming
following devastating floods we look at
what could be done
to adapt to our changing climate
and will tokyo 2020 be it the most
sustainable olympics yet
i'll be speaking to athlete and
environmental campaigner paula ratcliffe
hello and welcome to the uk's only
daily climate news show where we track
the changes happening to our world right
now
and we meet those coming up with the
solutions
now the met office will issue its first
ever extreme
heat warning today in the uk as
temperatures in parts of the country
continue to soar extreme heat episodes
in the uk are becoming more frequent and
prolonged
and can lead to increased energy use
wildfires
and problems as well for the health
service well our correspondent melania
veselinovich
joins me now melania what's going on
well the met office has introduced this
warning
together with public health england for
the first time this year in order to
increase preparedness and raise
awareness of the dangers that extreme
heat
can bring to health to infrastructure
some of those things as you mentioned
are increased
traffic to coastal areas people trying
to cool off by the sea perhaps
increased energy consumption using air
conditioning units perhaps which is
something that we hadn't really used in
this country before there's risk of
wildfires there's risk of people
presenting with health
problems related to heat to hospitals
which could put a strain on them and
potentially lead
to premature death so this is all very
concerning because the met
office says that these episodes are
becoming hotter they're becoming
more frequent and more prolonged
we do know that this warning has been
issued for
south wales west midlands south west
england and further east
into hampshire as far as the isle of
wight it is valid from
now until the end of thursday when the
heat is expected to start breaking down
a bit
all right so be careful melania thank
you
now germany's chancellor angela merkel
says that her country must do more to
tackle climate change
that's after record floods caused the
country's worst natural disaster
in nearly six decades as the waters
recede and clean up operations begin
the focus now turns to how to ensure
disasters like this
can't happen again as jonathan samuels
reports
in germany's our valley wine region they
live and work
close to nature they're also at her
mercy
vineyard owner frank josten believes
he's a victim of our reluctance to adapt
to climate change his home his
award-winning winery
his wife's business all but destroyed in
minutes
a community shattered we know a lot of
people
in that house over there and that those
over there
and the in the down level so they died
the people
all the people died chancellor angela
merkel warns
we must adapt to a world where natural
disasters happen with greater frequency
and intensity we have to hurry
we have to get faster in our fight
against climate change
and i believe that the european union is
working on just that
it's a message heard clearly here we are
not safe nature is stronger
than we are yeah and that's that's the
main message and that we see that we can
work with that yeah we have to we have
to find our
our agreements with the nature
how we manage our rivers build our towns
use our land
and conserve water are more crucial than
ever
being proactive rather than reactive
will save money
and lives despite all these regulations
they aren't always followed people still
build in flood plains
is it the same complacency is it the
same lack of awareness which you know
leads us to make the same mistake over
and over again
cutting co2 emissions is key to tackling
climate change
but with earth's temperature already now
above one degree celsius
we have to modify how we live our lives
to avoid pain
like the austin family is going through
jonathan samuels sky news availa
in germany now with the impacts of
climate change
already being felt around the world it's
not enough to just focus
on reducing emissions and limiting
global warming
adaptation and mitigation are important
to allow people to live with our
changing climate
instead of being forced from their homes
by it
for example in the united states miami
beach has been called the ground zero
of sea rise but the rising above program
aims
to mitigate against the worst effects it
includes elevating roads to fit new
drainage systems underneath
building sea walls and using data on
ocean levels to decide the height
of new buildings and intense heat waves
are becoming
more common due to climate change in
paris
a city-wide network of cooling islands
is being built including spaces such as
parks and pools
linked by cool walkways and the alentejo
region
in portugal is experiencing less rain
more frequent droughts
and substantially hotter temperatures
the city of evora
is using underground water sources for
irrigation
while nature-based solutions such as
more trees help provide
shade and improve flood resilience
and two-thirds of bangladesh is less
than
five meters above sea level so it's
vital that people there
find ways to adapt in the village of
kalibogi homes have been lifted onto
bamboo stilts
to help keep them dry and in the uk
a 20-year project on the norfolk broads
is stopping homes and farmland from
flooding
more than 240 kilometers of flood banks
are being upgraded using reused and
reclaimed materials
while a 10 kilometer stretch is being
replaced with
reed banks and lagoons and of course
technology is going to play an
increasingly
key role in fighting climate change and
adapting
to its impacts and today a new climate
action group
called subac has been launched to help
fund high-tech solutions to the climate
crisis
baroness bryony worthington is one of
the founders as well as one of the lead
authors of the 2008 climate change act
and she joins me now baroness
worthington really good
to talk to you i was mentioning the
launch today of
subac but you already have technology
within it don't you that's helping to
combat
climate change yes that's right thank
you
um we've set up an accelerator to help
not-for-profit enterprises who want to
make a difference on climate change to
collaborate
and to gain access to professional
skills so they can become more impactful
and they're calling it the climate subac
it's based on an
old idea of how you need to collaborate
to enable everyone to thrive
and we're really excited we've got five
really exciting organizations that are
kicking us off
as the founding members
when you see the scenes of devastation
across europe with the flooding
at the moment are there technological
solutions that you
envisage being able to help prevent that
kind of thing happening
so we are now into the age of
consequences um scientists have been
warning us
of this for decades and we've been
incredibly slow to act
and now really we've got to double down
on
both predicting how bad things are going
to get how quickly
preventing the worst from happening and
then surviving
through what's inevitable so that kind
of predict prevent and survive motto has
to be ingrained in everything that we do
and we are still you know in the
foothills really of understanding this
problem
it's really complicated the scale of
change that we need to adapt to is going
to be extraordinary and it's all
happening
in a time scale i think that even the
scientists are quite surprised by the
speed so
it's it's quite a serious effort and the
fact that it's taken
severe events in northern hemisphere
countries like canada like germany
to sort of put this on their front
headlines it is quite
astounding because these sorts of
impacts have been coming for many years
but they've perhaps not been taken as
seriously as they should have done so
if this does act as a wake-up call
that's great but we should have really
heeded these warnings a long time ago
okay baroness bryony worthington really
good to talk to you thank you
thank you very much well in today's
other climate news
thousands of hectares of land are
engulfed in smoke in siberia
as authorities tackle 187 forest fires
there
the kremlin has blamed the unprecedented
wildfires on unusually high temperatures
and climate change
the blazes mean that permafrost beneath
the ground is at risk of starting to
thaw
which could release huge amounts of
carbon into the atmosphere
the u.s special presidential envoy for
climate will visit the uk tomorrow
john kerry will make a speech at the
royal botanic gardens q
about the urgency of global climate
action
before traveling on to rome and naples
to attend the g20
ministerial meeting on environment
climate change and energy
he'll then return to london for
discussions about the cop 26 climate
conference
which is being held in glasgow in
november
and formula one driver sebastian vettel
has been photographed
litter-picking after the british grand
prix the four-time
world champion swapped his helmet for
bin bags to help cleaners with the
mammoth task
after 140 000 fans watched yesterday's
race
earlier this month vettel created a bee
hotel and
over the course of the race weekend
talked about his commitment to finding
long-lasting solutions for
sustainability
now the tokyo olympics start this week
and organizers have said that they hope
it will be the most sustainable games
yet
well they're using carbon credits to
offset emissions
claiming that this could mean the first
ever carbon
negative olympics the medals that will
be awarded to
athletes will use precious metals
extracted from used electronics
and competitors will even be sleeping on
cardboard beds
however a study published in the journal
nature found that from 1992 onwards
olympic games have been getting steadily
worse for the environment
as events become bigger and more
ambitious
well olympian and environmentalist paula
radcliffe is hoping that the games will
inspire us not only to get active but
also to go green paula radcliffe joins
me now
hello good to talk to you paula i know
you've been working with
nationwide trying to encourage people to
make their own homes
greener what have you made of the tokyo
games green credentials
well i think it's it's all a step in the
right direction i think
that the awareness amongst the whole
population
but certainly amongst athletes is is
really moving
much more to to appreciate the
environment if anything i think the
pandemic has taught us
to to see how important it is to do what
we can
now to preserve the environment it's for
not for our futures it's for the future
of our grandchildren and our great
grandchildren
and that's why it's a huge honor for me
to be working with nationwide on this
program because
the research that they have done shows
that 76
of us are already not using single-use
plastics anymore
they already know how to change on that
but people just aren't as aware
and i do think it's more of a
misunderstanding of what needs to be
done
in our own homes and maybe an
overestimation of the cost
as well now the tokyo games has a global
stage doesn't it's a great opportunity
to get some green
messaging out there what are some of the
challenges with an event that
size of keeping it green well i think as
you talked about the beginning the
challenge as the olympics have grown is
that people still need to they still
need to congregate in one place
people want to go and watch it um and
then that has to be then
beamed and sent all over the world and
all of that
costs a lot uh in terms of energy
um and so i think this year is certainly
helped if you like by the fact that it
is not a normal olympics there aren't
the numbers traveling out there that
there would normally be
um and so i think that will help to
contribute to making it more sustainable
and just even the fact that we're
thinking about it that making those
small steps
um for me that's always preferable than
doing nothing even if we look at it i
think
it's a huge task to get it anywhere
close to net zero
for for the olympics so let's not even
try i'd rather try and try and do small
amounts and i'm sure
if everybody feels like that then all of
our small amounts together that's why
we're stressing
what we can do yeah it's a marathon not
a sprint as they say paula radcliffe
good to talk to you definitely
thank you well that is everything from
us for today
coming up on the daily climate show
tomorrow how the drinks industry is
going green you can find out more here
tomorrow on
sky news thanks for watching
[Music]
you